I'm going to try to make this relatively
quick because I want to talk
work I adore and because it's subtle and
simple many people have gotten awards
around him
this gentleman has the ability to make
you love terrible people because he
loves them
this gentleman has the ability to show
you what you can be as an actor in all
the facets he is unlike almost anyone
else because when you look at I don't
know something like ordinary people and
you think my god how could he stay with
this woman she's horrifying but you stay
with her
because he loves her and the magic of a
great actor is to take you to a place
you don't want to go a great actor makes
you pay attention so if someone has
disappeared with your child and your
wife is kind of crazed and going to
psychics and you're seeing a little
person running around in a yellow
slicker and you think wow what's he
gonna do and you're riveted because you
know that whatever happens he's gonna
take you with him I always want to go on
the ride any actor takes me on it
actually makes me feel like I could get
better and that's what you want as an
actor at least I do I just want to get
better I want to be better
I want to make magic and Donald
Sutherland is one of the greatest
magicians ever
so congratulations you knocked me out
[Applause]